we'd like to thank nordpass for
supporting pbs
the american dream it's the idea that
in the united states upward mobility is
available
to everyone we're told from an early age
that if you work hard and sacrifice
one day you too will have a beautiful
family
money in the bank and of course your
very own house with a white picket fence
today we don't really appreciate how
radical this idea
is for most of human history real estate
was where money and power were wholly
concentrated
and only the most connected and wealthy
families could be landowners
since the 19th century millions of
people in our country
really did climb the socioeconomic
ladder this way
the creation of a burgeoning middle
class was a remarkable achievement
and a revolutionary step towards a
society in which wealth is shared
more evenly amongst its citizens but the
ugly truth
is that for decades the federal
government
intentionally created programs that
ensured the dream
only became a reality for one type of
person
and to this day we are dealing with its
consequences
[Music]
back in the 1930s our country was
reeling from
years of economic depression and housing
was in crisis
many banks had failed causing them to
call their loans early
contributing to a wave of foreclosures
home ownership across the nation
hovered around 45 percent and the
housing inventory that did remain
was tight especially for those in the
middle and lower classes
in response congress passed the national
housing act
in 1934 which created the federal
housing
administration the fha's job was to make
buying a house affordable to the
everyday person
mainly by offering to ensure certain
home loans against
borrower default this
government-sponsored
safety net gave private banks and
lenders the confidence
to extend much more generous terms than
had ever been available in the past like
30-year mortgages higher lending limits
and low
fixed rates the sort of things we take
for granted today
and it was a resounding success the fha
helped take the country's home ownership
rate from 43.6
to just under 70 by 2005.
heck we even got an fha loan when we
bought our house back in 2010.
thanks fha but there's a very big
difference between the original
fha mortgages and the ones we have
access to today
nowadays approval for an fha mortgage is
based on your personal financial
situation and creditworthiness
but originally fha mortgages focused on
some
other factors let's crack open the 1936
fha underwriting manual shall we
it stated if a neighborhood is to retain
stability
it is necessary that properties be
occupied by the same
social and racial classes schools
should not be attended in large numbers
by inharmonious racial groups
if the children living in such an area
are compelled to attend schools
where the majority of the pupils
represent a far
lower level of society or an
incompatible racial element
the neighborhood will prove far less
stable and
desirable so to quote the fha
communities of color were branded as
undesirable populations
and their mere presence would have a
detrimental influence on the housing
prices surrounding them
but this stance was not supported by any
evidence
in reality when people of color managed
to buy homes in mostly white
neighborhoods
the property values would go up because
they were willing to pay more due to the
shrinking housing inventory available to
them
nevertheless cities across the nation
ended up being divided into specific
zones by the fha and local housing
authorities
the areas where whites were more
concentrated got the green light for
those
sweet fha-backed loans but the areas
with higher concentrations of
communities of color
and immigrants were sectioned off on
maps with
red lines to indicate they were not
eligible for fha loans
regardless of individual financial
credentials
this practice now referred to as
redlining
also occurred for new affordable
developments popping up in suburbs
many of those builders even added
language to deeds
known as restrictive covenants with
phrasing like
no property shall be sold conveyed
rented or leased to
any person not of the white or caucasian
race
yep it was that explicit the combination
of federal policy and private sector
reinforcement
was devastatingly effective between 1934
and 1968 black families specifically
received only two percent of all
federally insured home loans and housing
segregation
tightened its grip on the american
landscape it wasn't until 1968 that
title viii of the fair housing act
finally outlawed housing discrimination
think about that
for 34 years an entire
generation of people denied access to
one of the biggest
tools of wealth building of the entire
20th century
it's depressingly easy to find evidence
of its impact
all these years later according to the
federal reserve
the typical white family today has eight
times the wealth of the typical black
family and five times the wealth of the
typical hispanic family
this is in large part due to home equity
being bequeathed from one generation to
the next
nearly 30 percent of white families
report receiving an inheritance or
monetary gift from family
compared to 10 percent of black families
and 7
of hispanic families and even though
it's been 52 years since those fha
policies were ruled unconstitutional
the gap between white homeownership and
black homeownership
is the worst it's ever been and even if
a black family
does own a home the typical value of it
is only
65 of the average white families
we even see this sort of divide play out
in the most
elite circles of the 616 billionaires
that call america home
only seven are black and none of them
the product of inheritance
and honestly the deeper you go on this
subject the more it feels like you're
peeling back
layers upon layers of rotted termite
infested wood
housing policy directly impacts
education because we fund our public
schools via
property taxes lower property values
means less money for schools resulting
in lower graduation rates lower college
attendance etc
then there's the impact on policing
incarceration rates
mental health even our diet areas with
higher concentrations of black latino
and indigenous americans
are far more likely to lack easy access
to fresh and affordable food
creating what are known as food deserts
this leaves the residents of these areas
more susceptible to
chronic health issues we here at two
cents
deeply believe that taking ownership of
your finances can completely
change the game but we collectively
have to acknowledge that the cards are
not fairly
dealt we are perfect examples of this
we take our financial responsibilities
very seriously through
budgeting saving and living within our
means but we
are fourth generation homeowners and
when we bought our
fha insured house a decade ago we were
graciously gifted some of our down
payment
our net worth like everyone else's
is due to a combination of choice and
circumstance we also hope this show
helps strip away the taboo from money
talk
how can we find solutions to issues that
we aren't educated on and don't converse
openly about
this subject is no different as the
writer tanahasi coates puts it
all of our solutions to the great
problems of health care
education housing and economic
inequality
are troubled by what must go unspoken
hopefully if enough of us honestly talk
about this
rigged game we just might be able to see
more people
actually win and that's our two cents
we'd like to thank nordpass for
supporting pbs nordpass is a new
generation
password manager where security meets
simplicity
nornpass remembers your passwords for
you by auto filling your username and
password
you can organize your logins and private
notes in a secure password vault with
access to them all
with one single master password there is
autofill with a click so you don't have
to scroll through hundreds of passwords
with one click nordpass will
automatically fill them in
there is zero knowledge your data is
encrypted on your device
before it reaches their servers for
backup and sync
for more information about the deal go
to
nordpass.com two cents
and use the code two cents hey everybody
we are back to answer some of your
questions
and reply to some of your comments on
our last episode which was
should the u.s government balance its
budget
all right our first comment that we're
going to address is from john l
he says all my life i heard that the us
government could print money if needed
i just thought it was an old wives tale
until now am i understanding this
correctly if they find themselves in hot
water
they can just print some more money also
is the us the only country that can do
this
or others can as well but we never hear
about this ability
what what john is alluding to here is
what economists now call modern monetary
theory it's just a theory
but it's kind of this idea of maybe we
should start thinking about the
the government printing more money
differently so to this first part of it
um will they can they just kind of make
more money to get out of hot water
no not necessarily because making more
money especially to a higher degree does
devalue the money
and so you can't just do this infinitely
or every time you get into trouble
and i actually don't know the answer to
that ending question which is is the us
the only country that can do this
i'm assuming not right what do you know
about that
so not every country can do this you
have to have a
sovereign currency for this to work so
because the u.s
has its own currency the dollar we can
do this because we fully control our own
currency
but the euro zone that has a lot of
different countries
with the same currency the euro cannot
do this
in the same way because they can't just
print more euros in one country
it's sort of a different system so our
second question comes from robert murray
do you two have any strong opinions
about modern money theory
like what stephanie kelton and al rangel
ray talk about
again this is a theory so it can
only be proven through practice
but we have a pretty good you know
history
that seems to prove this to be the case
i just listened to an amazing podcast on
this from planet money it's just called
modern monetary theory um
they interview stephanie kelton who is
kind of one of the
forefront thought leaders around
monetary theory
and hearing them talk through these
ideas and a lot of the old ways of
thinking that we kind of talked about in
this episode which is
we've got to balance our budget we can't
go into infinite amount of infinite
amounts of debt
um that has kind of proven not to be
true and finally
we definitely want to address the
somewhat elephant in the room
that nope brought up he said can you
guys do a video on this whole
gamestop thing we actually shoot videos
pretty far in advance so it's not really
in our capability to have something
happen and then
pump out something that week for it but
what we've decided after talking about
it that
what we want to do is take
the opportunity to dig more into the
idea of
derivatives i think it's so interesting
the the kind of match that
that ignited the whole 2008 crash
was derivatives if you've watched the
big short or anything kind of
exploring that a little bit and this
whole gamestop thing all about
derivatives too
so thanks so much for letting us know
how you feel
for chiming in and for watching us we
really appreciate it and we'll see you
next time see you later
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
if you want to get into the nitty gritty
of the home buying process
check out our video on the path to home
ownership
[Music]